[Musik]
hallo meine Lieben heute mache ich eine
Torte inspiriert von den Neapolitaner
Waffeln wenn ich nämlich mal so
durchschlendere durch die Gänge von
Kaufland und vor allem in der
süßigkeitenabteilung schaue was gibt's
Neues was gibt's auch altes und
traditionelles überlege ich mir was kann
ich hieraus zaubern und DAH habe ich mir
gedacht machen wir so eine richtig
leckere napolitaner knuspertorte wir
starten jetzt mit eines meiner liebsten
bodenrezepte nämlich mein blitzboden es
ist nämlich super unkompliziert einen
schnellen Boden selbst zu machen dafür
nehmen wir uns einfach zwei Eier am
allerbesten sind die jetzt auf
Zimmertemperatur dann lassen sie sich
nämlich auch richtig schön fluffig
aufschlagen und zur Unterstützung gebe
ich dazu noch zwei Esslöffel laubwarmes
Wasser und lasse das zusammen mit Zucker
und Vanilleextrakt 2 D Minuten richtig
schön dickcremig
[Musik]
aufschlagen
so sieht die Masse jetzt aus so richtig
schön dickcemig und jetzt können wir
weitermachen für das Rezept ist es
wirklich wichtig dass ihr sie eben
dickcremig aufschlagt weil sonst habt
ihr nur so ein kompakten Boden und ich
möchte ja gerne so ein fluffigen haben
so jetzt kommen die trockenen Zutaten
zum Einsatz Mehl back kau und Backpulver
ich schreibe euch übrigens alle ganz
genauen mengangaben wie immer unten in
die Infobox dann könnt ihr euch das
nämlich direkt screenshotten und dann
schnell rüber zu Kaufland und die ganzen
Zutaten besorgen das gebe ich jetzt hier
einmal durch mein Sieb und hebe das dann
ganz vorsichtig unter mit meinem
Teigschaber jetzt kommt nämlich keine
Maschine mehr zum Einsatz weil das muss
jetzt wirklich behutsam
[Musik]
passieren
sobald sich die Masse verbunden hat ist
sie schon fertig also nicht überrühren
sondern wirklich nur so lange wie
notwendig ich habe ja jetzt hier auch
schon mein Tortenring in Backpapier
eingeschlagen und auf 24 cm eingestellt
und jetzt werde ich einfach noch den
Boden einfüllen alles so ein bisschen
glatt verstreichen und dann im
vorgeheizten Backofen bei 180° Ober und
Unterhitze für ca 18 Minuten backen es
kann immer plus minus eine Minute länger
oder kürzer dauern bei euch schaut
einfach nach bzw öffnet jetzt nicht
unbedingt die Ofentür aber schaut auch
gerne schon nach 16 Minuten nach und
macht dann die
[Musik]
stäbchenprobe während der Boden jetzt
auskühlt habe ich mich schon mal um die
kuouvertüre für die Cremen gekümmert und
zwar habe ich einfach kuouvertüre in
meinen Schmelztopf getan und überm
Wasserbad langsam geschmolzen und
anschließend noch mal so 8 bis 10
Minuten auskühlen lassen dann ist zwar
die Kuvertüre noch flüssig aber eben
ausgekühlt und macht uns unsere Creme
jetzt nicht kaputt denn jetzt kommen
noch zum Einsatz Mascarpone Schmant und
Puderzucker und das gebe ich jetzt
einfach hier meine große Schüssel und
verrühre das zusammen mit der
geschmolzenen Kuvertüre
[Musik]
also ist super wichtig dass ihr eben die
kuouvertüre auskühen lasst damit es sich
so schön miteinander verbindet und dann
einfach komplett eine homogene Masse
wird und wenn die dann eben noch warm
ist und ihr sie dann mit zur mascpone
Creme gibt dann habt ihr Teller weil
dann die Schokolade eben klummt und fest
wird es ist jetzt auch nicht so schlim
wenn das passiert könnt das trotzdem
weiter verarbeiten aber das muss ja
nicht sein ich genehmige mir mal
was das ist so eine leckere Creme das
müsst ihr euch mal einfach merken für
weitere tortenprojekte wenn ihr mal eine
Creme ohne Sahne möchtet richtig lecker
und jetzt habe ich hier meinen
ausgekühlten Boden nehme jetzt zu
erstmal meinen backformlöser damit ich
mir jetzt den Boden eben nicht kaputt
reiße und gehe hier einmal richtig schön
am Rand entlang den Tortenring mache ich
sauber die Torte wird nämlich jetzt
gleich auf meine Tortenplatte gestellt
dann schön befüllt aber ich lasse mir ca
ich sag mal so ein zwei Löffel von der
Creme beiseite weil ich die Ränder damit
ganz grob einstreichen möchte die di
nämlich gleich so als Kleber für meine
napolitana
[Musik]
Waffeln so das ist jetzt übrig von
meiner Creme das gebe ich jetzt beides
einmal in den Kühlschrank aber nur für
20 bis 30 Minuten einfach damit so ein
bisschen sitzen kann die Kuvertüre da
drin wird ja dann auch noch mal die
Creme bisschen fester machen und
anschließend wie gesagt einfach nur noch
die Ränder einstreichen und mit den
Neapolitaner Waffeln schön ausschmücken
und ganz zum Schluss kommt für den
Crunch oben drüber noch gehackte
haseleskerne und das war's fertig ist
dann die
[Musik]
Torte i I don't wa for
you I
[Musik]
don't
fängt an zu reden ich dachte du F zu
reden ich dachte du fängst an zu reden
ich ma gerade jetzt wird
probiert hasenus pur oh lecker ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich habe gesagt das zu viel
hasenus drauf so von der Optik her aber
jetzt verstehe ich das es ist so dass
die Haselnusskerne in die Creme richtig
übergehen das schmeckt so im Mund als
wären die Haselnusskerne einfach in der
Creme mit verarbeitet dann kommt noch
dieser fluffige Schokoboden also so eine
richtig erfrischende und leichte Torte m
das schmeckt wie ein kennt ihr diese
locker leichten diese locker leichten
glasdesserts wo du so richtig mit dem
Löffel so voll durchgleitest so schmeckt
das nur als Torte das kannst du als Glas
machen ich schmeckt so lecker Leute mach
unbedingt nach jetzt halt dich fest F
Kalorien e keine Sahne in der Creme für
Leute die vielleicht mal keine
Küchenmaschine haben und Sahne
aufschlagen können einfach keine Sahne
in der Schmand und Mascarpone und
Kuvertüre rich lecker ich finde schmeck
die mascarpon so krass raus schmeckt
nicht so schwer meist bisschen
ich lieb Bo wir haben die ganze Zeit mit
Mundvoll gequatscht es tut uns leid aber
daran siht einfach wie lecker das
schmeckt ne also unbedingt nachmachen
Leute und bis zum nächsten Mal genau
[Musik]
tschüss